today's one minute monday is find a
mentor a mentor can help you minimize
your mistakes speed up your development
process and increase the chances of you
being successful i recently did a look
back on my youtube channel seeing how
far i've gone in the past five years i
spent the first four years on my own
learning making mistakes trying to get
better and i was doing pretty well but i
wasn't getting great results i was
getting a couple hundred views on a
video and a couple comments and those
one or two comments made my day and gave
me the energy to keep going that was
four years of suffering and grinding it
out and making videos consistently to
get better but my channel started to
really explode when i met my mentors
janie and steve they helped tell me what
i was doing wrong they helped me find my
passion and they helped me make my
videos so so so much better and now we
have over 4 million views on the channel
over 30 000 subscribers and lots of
comments on every video in less than one
year with them i was able to do more
than i could in four years on my own
that's the power of having a mentor so
reach out and find a mentor that can
help explode your business and then put
in the work the effort the hours to make
sure that their advice is going to good
use it could be the most important thing
that you do for your business this year
believe you guys like this video
subscribe to the channel let me know
what you think if you have a mentor you
want to give a shout out to leave it in
the comments thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you soon
i'm calvin moyer i'm a singer songwriter
and radio personality i subscribed to
eva's newsletter a few years ago it has
really helped me the newsletter is very
informative and inspiring and it has
helped me throughout my career so i
encourage you to don't give up you can
make it subscribe to evan's newsletter
today
you won't regret it
you